why we have friends for different
reasons there's gonna be times where you
guys hang out there's many times where
we hang out or people who have things in
common okay Rosa you're being ridiculous
you're trying to pick my friends away oh
my god if you feel that with and that's
between your friends I can't do anything
to take your friends away Betty you guys
Elena I am oh I am older than you I have
been insulted I have been in the beauty
industry for ten years okay I have been
blonde for ten years
okay lay off your own insecurities okay
I saw in myself
I'm sandy blue think I'm trying to be
like you please stop it right there but
if that makes you feel better about you
you know go ahead I didn't know Elena
had a claim on being the only little
blonde woman Elena I've looked this way
long before you came to America honey
she did the exact same thing to you and
didn't invite you to her wedding you
would have felt me like shafted and
she's trying to say she felt shafted I
can do whatever the hell I want mine to
your face I don't need that I'm done I'm
good luck you know what I'm done you're
done with me I mean if you want to wear
like you all whatever you okay whenever
I sleep
she is fake she is fake as my ass
you